[Music]
the demonstrations aniston of india
so for the socialist and
democratic group it was important to be able to
welcome during these two days the
women in vianne here in the
european parliament why because it  were
our candidates for the sakharov prize, it
was therefore important for us
as socialists and democrats to
give voice to these defenders
of women's rights in general and in
particular in afghanistan, so what have
we been able to do?  during these two
days there were three important panels that
worked on the different issues,
for example how to connect
women in exile because well not
only are they threatened they are
threatened at home but in addition she finds
herself in Europe or elsewhere and where
they can't connect with each
other but also reconnect with their
country
the city of yvelines with sandrine aubert
behind kostelic
[Music]
and souda  in
the second thing these days is
to continue to win are at the
center of our concerns we know a
crisis is chasing another there
was afghanistan with the taliban
today in ukraine tomorrow  there will
be another crisis and therefore it is
important to remain attentive to what is happening
in this country we have a responsibility we
have been present for 20 years as
Western forces on a military level in
the country but also with approaches  of
support, for example, for 20 years we have
helped many women to pursue
education, what are we doing
now with this woman, so
to keep Afghanistan at the heart of
our concerns and to rebuild
an Afghanistan where it could  there is
something other than the taliban the taliban
they are there today will they still be there
tomorrow and therefore we have to prepare
this future
will give us
access
to the docks we have to show michel
baylet heard it a lot of witnesses  people who
say but in the end you have spent a
lot of money but the populations
have not necessarily seen the
color of this money
and what it tells us is today
with the Taliban be careful not
to continue in  the same logic, that is
to say not to give money to the
Taliban so that they can use it for themselves
but also for their friends, which will
consolidate power, so we have to
find ways to help
in afghanistan but but that this
really helps where women are, for
example the opening of schools,
giving access to hospitals and so all that
will have to be really cut with a scalpel
to ensure that these women
really receive  european aid
free dont murders of the world as
we achieve miniature
industeel buyster believe in my country
haiti believe in my friends and i know
you want to be